من التلسكوبات إلى مصادم الهادرونات الكبير
كل أداة علمية جديدة تعيد صياغة الأسئلة
التي نستطيع نحن كعلماء
وعقول فضولية أن نطرحها بشكل منطقي
الحوسبة عالية الأداء أو HPC
انضمت إلى تلك القائمة المرموقة في الستينيات، واليوم
تطرق الحواسيب الكمومية الباب ذاته.
أهلًا، اسمي Iskandar Sitdikov
وأنا مهندس برمجيات هنا في IBM Quantum
في هذا الكورس نهدف إلى تعليم الطلاب
والمهنيين كيف ستعمل الحوسبة الكمومية قريبًا
جنبًا إلى جنب مع بنى HPC التحتية
لتقديم قدرات حوسبية
ستتعلم كيف تتواصل الحواسيب الكمومية
والكلاسيكية وتتبادل البيانات
وكيف تكتب برامج تستغل كلا النوعين من الأجهزة
وكيف يفتح هذا التكامل تطبيقات لا نستطيع حلها اليوم
ستكتسب خبرة عملية مع أجهزة كمومية حقيقية
وعناقيد HPC الكلاسيكية عالية الأداء
لتشغيل وظائف كمومية جنبًا إلى جنب مع أعباء HPC التقليدية
وتفسير النتائج بثقة
وتحديد الأماكن التي يمكن للتسريع الكمومي
أن يساعد فيها الحسابات بشكل حقيقي
وأين لا يجدي، وقبل كل شيء ستفهم
إلى أين تتجه مستقبل الحواسيب
والخريطة القديمة التي ستأخذنا هناك. نعتقد
أن هذا الكورس مهم
وفي الوقت المناسب ونؤمن
أن الجمع بين هذه التقنيات سيكون ضروريًا
لتحقيق الميزة الحسابية
قد يكون لهذا تأثيرات واسعة النطاق عبر الصناعات
مثل الكيمياء، مما يتيح ربما
تصميم أدوية أسرع وأبحاث المواد
في المالية
لنماذج مخاطر أذكى
وكشف الاحتيال في الذكاء الاصطناعي وتعلم الآلة
لتحسين النماذج. في هذا الكورس
سنتعمق في موارد الحوسبة
ونماذج البرمجة والخوارزميات الكمومية
فأهلًا بك وتحمّس
الكثير لنناقشه